one only one project I could spend their
money pretty quickly I think
my billion dollars goes on micro wind
farms no I don't really think I do want
to billion dollars of my crew in the
farms I'm just kind of I'd spend a
billion dollars on teaching a hundred
million people how to draw and paint
because that's how I get most fun and
that's how I really understand the world
well a billion dollars actually isn't
enough what I want is essentially the
entire budget of the US government in
addition to its yearly spending and I
want to give it to all the special
interest groups which are distorting our
economy and buy them out and say in
exchange for getting rid of the special
deals that you have we will pay this
amount of money now and we will come up
with a rational tax code and various
other things
well I'd split it up into two pieces and
the first piece I'd used to fund a new
state-of-the-art climate model that
resolves the features of our atmosphere
and ocean at a higher resolution than
we've ever done before so that we can
start to look more carefully at issues
like how climate change is going to
influence weather patterns and
hurricanes and those sorts of things
with the remaining money I would fund a
an outreach project aimed at
communicating our science to the public
and putting scientists in touch with
communicators to try to improve the
public understanding of our science I'd
set up a crazy science fund so that we
could find all those things which are
just too much out the box to attract
conventional funding I'd like to give
people a chance to be a little more
risk-taking in science and then people
have grown accustom over the last decade
or so I'll give you one example the
United States spends five billion
dollars a year on cancer research but
almost all of it is directed at really
safe and imaginative things an awful lot
of genomics and proteomics and so on I'd
like to see one billion of that five
billion dollars spent on crazy ideas
in controlling cancer I would I would
develop some kind of systemic critical
thinking curriculum that should be
taught everywhere around the world to
all kids that is not what to think but
how to think if I was limited to one
project I'd have to make that making
science a way of thinking for as much of
the world as possible I'd spend a
billion dollars trying to get people
understand that part of being human is
actually thinking scientifically which
involves imagination and discovery
there's no species that has that
capacity except humans I'd spend a
billion dollars trying to make that the
most important thing that we do in our
lives
buying a large tract of wilderness on a
pessimistic day I'd say family planning
but on an optimistic day just just
buying the wilderness would be a would
be enough
I would fund a prize in aging research a
big one it's interesting to saw to sort
of solve one disease after another but
the fundamental problem is that people
wear down and get old and a dressing
that could really change the world
there's its enormous waste of resources
when people die after you know
accumulating knowledge and wisdom and
working
you